Some of you might
be wondering, why
are we even worried about
this Drake equation,
or why are we even tempted
to go through this thought
experiment of the number
of detectable civilizations
in the galaxy when we
don't have a clue of some
of these assumptions?
We don't know what fraction of
planets capable of sustaining
life actually do generate life.
We don't know of all of
the planets that have life,
what fraction of those planets
go on to have intelligent life,
and what fractions of
those civilizations
go on to using
electromagnetic radiation
as a form of communication.
We don't know these answers.
In fact, we probably
won't know some
of these answers for some time.
So what's the point of
going through this exercise?
And that is a valid
point of view.
The Drake equation, or
even this little equation
that we've set up here,
it's not an equation
in the traditional sense, where
we can immediately apply it
to some engineering problem,
or some physical problem,
or anything like that.
I view it more as a bit
of a thought experiment.
And what's interesting
about it is
it kind of can structure our
thought around the problem,
and I think that's where
it has the most value.
We'll probably not get a solid
number on this any time soon,
but it does lead us to thinking
about these interesting
problems of what
does it mean, or what
do we think has to happen for
a planet to start getting life,
even if it has all
the right ingredients?
And then what does it mean
for things to eventually get
to the point that you
have intelligent life?
And in all fairness to this is
that probably 200 years ago,
there would have
been no way to even
have a decent estimate of the
number of stars in the galaxy.
Now we're starting to
do an OK job on that.
20 or 30 years
ago, it would have
been viewed impossible to say
the fraction of stars that
have planets, but now
we're finding exoplanets.
We're seeing stars wobble.
We're getting more and
more accurate instruments.
So we can start to think
about planets that are closer
to the size of Earth's.
We're making headway there.
There's other indirect
methods to think about,
well, some of these
exoplanets look
like they're in the
right zone, and they
look like they have the right
chemical signature based
on other information
that we're getting,
and that maybe they are
capable of sustaining life.
So as time goes on, and
as technology improves,
we might be able to get better
and better and better at this.
But with that said, it's not
going to happen any time soon,
and the real value
of all of this
is really to
structure our thoughts
about really, a super,
super interesting topic.
Now, the other thing
I want to talk about
is a slight
clarification of what
I talked about in
the last video.
In the last video
for this l, I said
it's the civilization's
lifespan,
but what's actually
relevant is the lifespan
of the civilization
while it is detectable.
So, detectable.
So it doesn't matter if the
civilization is around 100,000
years, but it's not
releasing any type of thing
that we can detect.
That's not what we care about.
We care about that the 5,000
years, or the 10,000 years,
or the 100,000 years
when they are actually
using some type
of communications,
or some type of
electromagnetic radiation
that we can eventually detect
once those things reach us.
Now, the other thing
I want to make clear
is we're talking
about the number
of detectable civilizations
in the galaxy right now.
And I'll write now
in quotation marks,
because we're not talking about
a civilization that is maybe
even a peer civilization
with us that developed radio
communication on the
order of 100 years ago,
because frankly, they
would have to be no more
than 100 light years
away for us to be
able to detect
those signals now.
If they were on the
other side of the galaxy,
we wouldn't be able to detect
their for tens of thousands
of years.
So when I talk about
now, I'm saying
that the signals
are getting to us.
Signals getting,
signals received.
The signals are being
received right now.
So you could have a civilization
that developed radio
70,000 years ago, but they're
70,000 light years away,
and maybe they collapsed
10,000 years later,
but we're just receiving
their first radio signal.
So that would be
as a civilization
that I would count in this
equation we're setting up.
And so just to make
sure we understand it,
and then we can play
with some numbers,
let's remind ourselves.
This is the number of
stars, our estimate
of the number of
stars of the galaxy.
Multiplied by this,
you now know the number
of stars in the galaxy
that have planets.
You multiply by this n sub p,
the average number of planets
capable of sustaining life,
and these first three terms
will give you the average
number of planets--
or I should say the number,
the total number of planets
in the galaxy that have been
capable of sustaining life
at some point in their history.
Multiply it by this.
This is the number of planets in
the galaxy that have sustained
actual life, not just
capability of it.
They actually had life on them
at some point in their history.
Multiply it by this,
this is the fraction
that have developed intelligent
life on these planets.
The number of planets
with intelligent life
at some point in their history.
Multiply it by this fraction.
All of these terms.
We have the number of
planets in the galaxy that
have had intelligent life
that became detectable,
that started emitting some
type of radio signature.
We don't know,
some type of thing
like that at some
point in their history.
So over here, all of
these first six terms
tell us the number of
detectable civilizations that
occurred at some point in
the history of the stars,
the solar systems, the planets
that are out there right now.
But we care about the ones
that are detectable now.
We don't care about the
ones that came and went,
and their radio signature went
past us while we were still
living in caves, or we
were hunter gatherers.
We care about the ones
that the radio signatures
are receiving us now.
And that's why we have this
little term right over here.
So this is the
civilization of-- or I
guess you could say
this is the length
of the detectable civilization.
So while they were actually
releasing a radio signature
divided by the life of that
planet, or that solar system,
or that star.
So for any given
star or planet that
meets all of these
criterion, what's
the probability that it's
releasing its-- so at some
point in the history, there
was a detectable civilization
or more that was releasing
some type of a radio signature.
But what's the probability
that it's doing it right now?
And so that's the
detectable life span
of that civilization divided by
the life of that solar system,
or of that planet.
Because frankly, the
star and the solar system
and the planet, they're
all going to essentially
have, give or take, a few
hundreds of thousands of years,
or even a few millions
of years, because we're
thinking in the
billions here, they're
going to have roughly
the same life span.
And so let's say, and just
to make this a little bit
more tangible, let's say
that the sun has a lifespan,
and let's say that with the
Earth and our solar system,
has a lifespan of
approximately 10 billion years.
10 billion years.
And let's say that us as humans,
let me be pretty optimistic
about it, let's say that we are
detectable as a civilization
for one million years.
Our best days are ahead of us.
We are detectable for
one million years.
So this term right over
here will be 1 million
over 10 billion.
So this will be 1/10,000.
So even though we might
be around sending out
detectable signals
for a million years,
the odds relative to the
entire span of the history of--
And I'm making some
simplifying assumptions here,
but relative to the
entire span of the history
of our planet and our
sun, if someone is just
randomly sampling
our solar system
at a random time in its
history, in a random part
of this 10 billion
years, there's only a 1
in 10,000 chance that they'll
be sampling us at a time
that we are releasing signals.
Assuming that there weren't
any other civilizations on Mars
or Venus, or whatever
else, that there
weren't any other civilizations
on Earth hundreds of thousands
of years ago that
were doing this,
they'll definitely only
have a 1 in 10,000 chance
of detecting us, assuming
that they're sampling.
There could have been
a civilization that
was around three
million years ago,
and they did this whole search
for extraterrestrial life.
Maybe they're 20, or 100,
or 1,000 light years away,
and they pointed their
radio telescopes at us.
But a million or two
million years ago,
they would have pointed at
the direction of our sun,
and they would have not
gotten any radio signals,
and they're like, man, when
is extraterrestrial life going
to show up?
Even though the sun and Earth
does eventually develop us,
they weren't able to observe
us because when they sampled
was outside of that
1 in 10,000 window.